New York Queen turn off our overhead
home are you talking to you know what
just making a little video to chat you
know you can't show it to anyone
yeah the way narrating in that voice oh
[__] so what they call you happy come on
I'm not carrying your bags
go hey should I go to the bathroom
before there's a bathroom on it
whoa no pirate that's awesome there he
is it is you first time on a private
plane it's on anyway shouldn't make a
Hanoi
no one has actually told me why I'm
doing or what I'm doing something about
Captain America going crazy
this is your home neighbors when our
roommate yeah okay there you got that
you got what the hell are you wearing a
suit
where's the case okay what part of the
coin this is so much oh please my room
is way bigger of it alright okay sound
of just decided it minor upgrade oh my
gosh put it on this is the closing hours
it let's go
yeah I don't understand is it for me
happy happy wait this is insane insane
look at this thing look look at the is
written okay Captain America Iron Man
like Widow I got a guy go
high fiving Captain America I stole the
shield not threw it at him he's big now
I gotta go she was throws amazing things
that have missiles arrows and I just
wanna flip tin I so much you love
everybody in it hey take a second honey
hey listen walls here well you don't
know video diary so it I chosen not to
do it he was filming everything on the
way to chip hey you know we should
actually we should make an alibi video
for your hand anyway you're ready hey
how you doing what do you wear something
skimpy I hope you did that day
appropriate all right let's start over
you can edit it 3-1 hey May
my gosh I want to tell you what a
incredible job
your nephew did this weekend at the
stark internship
everyone was impressed Maude
it's a frigging emergence because you're
not in Queens Boulevard see happiest is
hoping to get bumped up to asset
management he was for head of security
and before that it was just a driving
private conversation I don't like
talking about it was hard for me to talk
to me
no seriously position order but happy
can you give us a moment they want me to
read that Peters case out of the trunk
I think you two yes what we're just
talking about
give me a favor though Happy's kind of
your point behind this don't stress him
out don't do anything stupid
I've seen his cardiogram all right yes
don't do anything I would do and
definitely don't do anything wouldn't it
there's a little gray area in there and
that's where you operate
what does that mean in Amin identity is
it seven four I need to go you you're
gonna take it I guess I can't think I do
what's the matter
watch your little floor two larvae not
larvae enough how many times you have to
say an alarm before you talk to me you
know I love you stress the internship
and I'm tired it's dark internship I
have to do not a fan of that Tony Stark
after an ATM robbery was boarded by
Queens own colorful local crime stopper
the spider-man as decider can monitor
attending our last was set off yeah yeah
yeah core six blocks away from us
Regan ordered from how oh he loves you
how'd you find me you put a tracker my
suit I put everything you see including
this year
[Music]
they'll be your the spider-man
come on shooting wasn't it what are you
doing in my room mail at me and you said
there's a Death Star's and nobody knows
why me mrs. don't know if you mean my
super - usually star creature
what are you an adventure basically
anybody that this guy too busy or level
with you I'll guarantee the synchronous
aquarium ever have the moon cometary
medicine school tomorrow okay for heat
can you speak Anna you have any idea no
can you summon an army of spiders no man
I know I am too just uh she'll be
stopped
Maryland what's there god no evil lair
do a winter dude
a gang with alien guns run by a guy with
wings yeah they have a lair but uh but
how are you gonna get there for sleep
300 miles away not too far from DC hey
waiter yeah I was hoping maybe I could
rejoin the team no no way you can't just
quit on a stroll up and be welcomed back
by everyone hey welcome back Peter flash
you're back - first alternate what he's
making opening to me can we go already
because I was hoping to get into some
light protesting tunnel ones the embassy
for dinner protesting is patriotic let's
get on the bus together super
this is gonna change our lives
okay
laughs spider-man swinging say you guys
are tight and then I get a fist bump or
one of those half-broken can't believe
you guys are this land party
you're sure ki am I
[Music]
by yourself immediately
go on go on prom night
the joint venture between Stark
Industries in the federal government the
Department of damage control will
oversee the collection and storage of
alien and other exotic materials
experts estimate there are over 1500
tons of exotic materials scattered
throughout the tri-state area hey chief
you still have another load from
yesterday let's turn this in right I and
all in it too bad could have made some
pretty cool stuff from all that alien
junk I'd say what let's keep it well
it's changing time we change too
great job Peter 98 percent successful
maybe I flash it up and go with this
come on
sure NBA Finals party I need to sign off
on the guest list
I left the guest list to you I said keep
it sophisticated done good did you bite
the kid you said keep it sophisticated
why do you hate fun you really want me
to invite the kid if I might think here
then I gotta babysit I like the kid I
want you to invite the kid
can I please shave us off no you may not
because your team lost therefore you
have to look like me indefinitely which
one go for a third option get out Friday
run a final check on the party list
question Captain Steve Rogers too soon
sending invites no way I'm gonna watch
the NBA Finals with mr. stork so you're
gonna let me go ha nice try buddy
[Music]
Oh perfect timing I need to go downtown
and get me snacks with Tim Duncan happy
the game starting here faster than
delivery with the whole thing now
remember it's for Tim Duncan so nothing
fancy just the fundamentals come on
let's go I'm expecting change
you guys are really Luud up my night
just want to watch the game I think I
know that guy
hey happy kid where are you mr. stark
mad I'm not there devastating
where are the crackers I'm getting them
right now is there anyone Wow your DJ
can't read you spider-man what are you
doing here I'm going to this violence
parties darks party I'm going to look we
get a picture it's really welcoming
thank you Wow me that's that we are
first another one another another I
gotta go out of my skin keep the change
can't believe I'm watching this I see
this is stalking
[Music]
[Applause]
MJ MJ called me magic is so for Tim
Duncan he's right over there
[Music]
Morgan please did you feel
what you wanted to watch the game
[Applause]
got my change these are great you what
time Thanks
you